foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
day of the year day one and day two of
March Madness are probably better but
this is up there man this is just a
beautiful day I got producer Ryan with
me producer Ryan how you doing what
Super Bowl food are you eating what
stupid props are you betting you know
give me a quick overview so here's my
thing is like I when I get nervous I I
can't eat so while everyone else is in
the whole Super Bowl yeah when everyone
else in the whole like Super Bowl food
game I'm kind of out of that because I
can't eat I will say this I saw on Tick
Tock you know our good friends uh Bryson
and Ritter did a whole uh draft of food
two of Ritter's picks were not food it
was beer and guacamole he picked a drink
and a condiment so I think guacamole
counts
um
I don't know all right I just wanted to
get that out there let's start the show
for real welcome to the show like I said
Super Bowl Sunday could could not be
more excited
um Greg is not with us today but we
still got business to take care of we
still have to provide locks we got to
build a parlay we got to give out some
Best Bets there's you know this is one
of the best betting days of the year so
um producer Ryan why don't you why don't
you talk to people through what we're
what we're going to do here first
yeah so we're going to do what we always
do right we need your locks we need your
hot takes
um when we you know again when we ask
for a leg it's not like what I said
before it's like when you're doing a
food draft you don't drop you know a
drink and a condiment we need your locks
we need something we're going to put it
to this parlay and win for this game so
let's get started I mean we've got we've
got draftings pulled up here uh what do
we like so I see Jay Gonzalez already
trying to push Travis Kelsey Jalen hurts
anytime TD
fox Sam well I do think we you know
obviously everyone wants to come in here
and talk ball I do think we should ask
the chat is guacamole acceptable to take
in a Super Bowl food draft because I
actually would say it is beer I think
all right guacamole I'm fine to take so
the crazy thing here is is that Ritter
is in this chat and I haven't heard a
single defense yet so I mean that that
is wild to me not a single yeah not a
single guacamole take it's I it's a
condiment I don't know what you're gonna
say it doesn't pass the your mom asking
you if you ate something today and you
said yeah I had guacamole no fair enough
all right we can we can get in we can
get into business I do think you're
you're starting off this the right way
like it's hard to imagine that when we
build this parlay that we won't have
either a Jalen hurts anytime TD or
Travis Kelsey anytime TD right like
there's no way we're walking out here
with that so I do think we should Tee It
Up to the chat which one of those do we
want more because we're gonna have one
and yeah what would what would your take
be I know you're a tight end guy so I'm
assuming you want Kelsey oh dude I'm a
huge tight end guy the problem today is
I love the other two I like I think
Kelsey's gonna score but you know me I'm
gonna push my my propaganda of higher
odds I like Dallas Goddard today and I
love Noah gray today I love Noah gray I
mean we can't that's like a sprinkle on
the side we can't start we can't start
the parlay with that people are gonna
you know throw Mutiny in the chat if we
do that
um
yeah that's true it's it it is either
though like all you're seeing like every
other comment is to aylin Kelsey Jayla
or Kelsey yeah so let's just yeah um I
don't know should we like throw one in
there and like just see if we get the
thumbs up thumbs down or you know
um I don't know what do you think
great comment from Zibby Sam is here so
we shall win now that's great Ritter
send him some BR betting socks
um um I I will say there are some takes
in here about guac of whether it's good
or not guac is great I did not say guac
is not good guac is awesome it's just
it's not a food so I mean that's that's
all it is uh
I think we throw Kelsey in here I do
like I feel like that is probably what
the chat wants
um
and we see what the chat says and then
we sort of go from I think let's put
that in and then we can kind of dive
into you know I'm hosting the show I've
never done this before so I don't really
know what I'm doing so I would say put
that in and then let's move around to
some of the alternate rushing yards
receiving over stuff like that that
would be my take but again don't know
what I'm doing
I agree I agree with the take I'm seeing
some gainwell touchdowns in here I think
we play it safe for right now with
Travis Kelsey we'll put it in and then
and then let's move I don't see a world
in which Travis Kelsey doesn't score
that's the thing it's like it's one of
those that everyone's gonna be like oh
it's so obvious it can't hit oh the
Public's taking Travis Kelsey but it's
like
they're when they're gonna we're in the
Red Zone they're gonna throw the Travis
Kelsey so I I it's like one of those
it's like it's gonna hit you know right
or Noah gray and then our life is ruined
you know yeah I
um all right so all right we need
another I need another tape because I'm
not just Kenneth gainwell over 18 and a
half rushing yards from flyman
see my problem is when we did the show
earlier this week with Calvin Johnson
the number was at 14 and a half and I
loved that number at 14 and a half yeah
I don't love the number at 18.
okay times fair struggling
I don't I don't disagree I do think like
I do think the Eagles backfield Eagles
rushers in general are kind of going to
be hard to read here because they're all
like they're all super talented
um that's why I like Boston Scott as
interesting because you only need like
eight yards 10 yards but you know no
spoiler alerts
um
we wait for the chat to tell us about
Austin Scott we can't we can't push the
Boston Scott propaganda
um
Jalen Russia okay it hurts over 50
rushing yards that one okay that one I
do like
because
you know I think the Eagles especially
since Hertz has gone back from injury
and I think less so in the playoff games
is obviously it's like you burn the
boats in the playoff game but like I
think they've tried to protect him a
little bit but it's like this is the
Super Bowl like you are going to unleash
every you know every thing you can get
out of Jalen hurts you're gonna get him
moving the Chiefs have struggled with
mobile quarterbacks so I actually think
that's like a pretty interesting one
I I don't hate it I will also say I've
gotten uh information from our friend
bagel and locks that the most uh bet
prop in America is Kenneth gainwell's
over rushing yards
um
yeah and he didn't say it but it implies
that I'm sharp
um because I you know I'm not taking it
right yeah so am I sharp who knows
uh all right so I guess that it just
depends what number we want to take with
you're talking about J we're talking
about Jayla do you like Jalen hurts and
the is the chat all in on Jayla Hearts I
do want to get some final final takes on
the chat here is that that's just my
take I like Jalen hurts we're getting
and we're also getting some and I don't
want to ignore the people who want to
take my homes under Rush uh 19 and a
half rushing yards oh I mean dude could
we just take listen if we wanted to take
the lowest number for Jalen hurts which
was 30 34 and a half over why don't we
just take Patrick Holmes under 34.5
rushing yards we could take both though
like we could I mean like that's also
like it makes you be rushed guys
we could be kiwi Rush guys
are recording the nickname are we could
we be Big Time Rush no I like that I
guess it's just one guy um there is some
some Patty Mayo two plus TDS in the chat
um I don't listen I don't hate the
Mahomes I think Patrick Mahomes gonna
have a great day I just think that under
34 and a half rushing yards might be the
easiest play that we put into this
I I'm down to throw it in and sort of
get takes in the chat yeah see Thomas
says under 34.5
I I do think like he's
he's probably gonna move uh obviously a
lot better than he did in even the last
game just having the extra rest but that
is still a lot of rushing yards for for
my homes 35.
yes yeah and like I can see him cashing
the 19 and a half the over for the 19
and a half but 34 and a half I mean good
God like that's that's way too much for
a guy whose ankle may or may not be in
one piece
yeah I don't I don't hate that
um the chat doesn't love the Jalen hurt
stuff just to yeah I thought that was
interesting too
um we have Mike Steve Ritter in the chat
never heard of that guy
um AJ Brown five plus receptions which I
feel like we've done the AJ Brown
receptions thing before and I feel like
it it didn't work out but I could be
wrong
yeah we also have it in another in the
yeah that's true in the Calvin I don't
know if I want to vote I don't know if I
want to push yeah I I would like the the
capability to be able to hit either one
and not get burned so let's let's we
should look for an eagles prop here
though you know we've got two chiefs
ones we should let's go
um let's go to the Eagles receivers
though you know could be a big Devonte
Smith game
I'm seeing Dallas Goddard over four and
a half receptions from flymon and then
bagel and lox wants his yards
I don't know I guess it's a good
question
like the lowest is 34 and a half
or we can go do
I don't know what the lowest we can do
tease his reception receptions yeah
scroll down yeah scroll down
scroll down you know what I I I want to
stay here on the Eagles because we
should have some Eagles props I did see
a lot of reports that the Chiefs plan on
getting Kadarius Tony heavily involved
in their game plan I don't know if you
saw those as well but
uh I'm not on the chief's beat
unfortunately but you know I trust her
you gotta you gotta explore all avenues
um yeah
so wait what was the what is goddard's
um so four plus is minus 360. what's his
like standard line five and a half
five and a half five and a half I mean
four plus is pretty good I can do some
quick research here but I can't imagine
um it's been that much that he doesn't
get four catches
there's a chat like that we got yes on
Goddard receptions
from 11 to 202.
it's pretty good
it's pretty good yeah Michael Boling
Juju over 200 receiving yards now that
that is a hot take flyman likes Dallas
over four and a half receptions
wow Jack Zulu Hertz plus three ints rels
big on Kadarius Tony yeah the kidoni
Scoops are
Gary's Tony's there's Tony excuse me I
told you I was gonna mess up I'm all
flustered for most in the show uh but
Canary's Tony over this might be worth a
look
um I think that's a great thing that's
good
I do like Goddard here nice nice safety
blanket for hurts and you know the
biggest game of his life
yeah I I mean we can talk about Tony's
receiving yards I mean the chat likes it
you drop the lock uh we see and this is
this is where I'm gonna get
a little bit tilted because I don't hate
the idea of all it takes is one to him
yep yep and I think we need something to
kind of push the odds up a little bit
yep
I I like the 35 Plus I won't lie oh man
that's risky so obviously no hard men
everyone else is a full go though so but
that that core has been banged up so
like even though like everyone is
playing I don't know maybe maybe they're
not full you know fully ready to go
maybe that opens up more time for him
well I don't know I feel like let's
let's throw in well how are we doing
four or five legs here
five okay let's throw in the minus 145
because if we throw a 35 Plus I think
the chat might turn on us
um
like what that did
you like that
I dude I mean we're at plus 390 we have
one that's pretty good that's pretty
good man
um chat you know thumbs up thumbs down
are you liking the parlay so far there's
a it is interesting and you know there's
a lot of anytime TD love in this chat
now I think we only do one anytime TD
because I feel like that's the riskiest
that's always the riskiest one in my
opinion
um
but there is a lot anytime TD 11 in in
the chat
I know and I'm starting to see some
Dallas Goddard anytime TD miles Sanders
as well
I think we did the right move it's not
like Kelsey's minus 200 you know I mean
you're the Earth coming in here and
wanting a minus you know 750. right
there very special
[Laughter]
um a lot of uh a lot of love for the
Eagles defense and sacks
um we add team tax into this
I can't remember see
I could never remember
um
just hit one total so we could do oh
Eagle sax made yeah I interesting
yeah I mean
they have the best
they have the best pass rush in football
right there at the Cowboys rest in peace
but they actually converted into sacks
unlike the Cowboys who let the play go
along so
um the only thing here is that the
chief's offensive line is obviously very
strong but two seems pretty pretty damn
juicy I can't lie
was there a need to bring the Cowboys
into on Super Bowl Sunday well because
like they actually do have pretty close
pass rushes in terms of it was actually
it was a it was a complex all because
the the the Cowboys it's like just as
good but the Eagles convert them into
sacks or the Cowboys just get a lot of
pressures but pressures are good we like
pressures
so two plus is that what we're doing
um
who suggested it is really really happy
with us right now and wants us to do too
um yeah well he's happy okay I mean he
said thank you for listening Jesus so I
mean like that that was also accomplish
salt because it's like that's right
listening to me you usually ignore me uh
so uh Ritter wants four plus four plus
would be plus 195. I think
it's so nice that 500 plus 500 is so
clean it's just like such a clean number
I also feel like I I be honest with you
I don't really know any of these legs
that like make it aren't hurting yeah no
yeah it's actually pretty good actually
and like I'm I'm okay with the odds here
like this is if we were let's because I
am seeing three plus I'm not saying
let's do it I'm just saying let's
entertain it and see what it would be
what is it at uh yeah I mean like the I
mean I get the the desire to want to do
that it's Plus 700.
yeah but I think my gut is if they did
get two and you know we we would it
would haunt us and you want to win
you don't want to be at your Super Bowl
party been like oh man I was one leg
away you want to sit next to every all
of your friends and be like yeah I
cashed a five to one lay and I hit my
coin toss bet and I hit my Anthem bet
like you want the winner so that that
would be my take
uh
uh I do agree with you also this you
know I don't wanna you know I don't
wanna get too confident but like to hit
your pretty good you know to hit your
parlay at halftime that would be pretty
good that's what this is that's what
this is telling me right now that's
pretty uh all right so let's put it back
let's put the two back in and let's ask
the chat for a little thumbs up thumbs
down what we think of the parlay
um
yeah so there was Zippy rels and C
Thomas all said three plus and then we
got a little bit of a counter protest
from some people in the chat wanting to
keep it at two so yeah I think this is a
good we're Landing in a good place
thumbs up or thumbs down uh Ritter says
he's good with delay Ritter also thinks
walks of food so like that's we have
problems there
um I'm actually team Ritter here but I
don't want to derail the conversation
I think what counts I think what counts
you're you're doing a show with me
though right so it's like to to kind of
like go against wow all right transition
chat you know early early liking it
thumbs up fire thumbs up
guac is clearly clearly a food question
is whether it's a meal that's a good
take not a food I I again if your mom
asked you if you ate something today and
you said yeah I had guac what would your
mother [__] they'd be like oh you know
avocado you know it's not a lot of
protein you know did you even an avocado
it's like you put it on like toast or
you put it on your sandwich you don't
eat it out of you don't scoop an avocado
my well I will say my favorite part is
Max ruxel and the trap trying to
disagree with you but he keeps auto
correcting food to good and then having
to fix it with a follow-up message like
the third time
um all right I I like this parlay
um Brian we locking this in
yeah let's let's lock it in all right
I'm getting hate for the squawk stuff
just you need to all right read the read
the parlay for the people and tell them
where they can tell it for us and and
we'll we'll keep it moving yes sir all
right so we got Travis Kelsey anytime
touchdown Pat Mahomes on one ankle under
34 and a half rushing yards Dallas
Goddard four plus receptions Kadarius
Tony or cadone as we've now coined his
name 25 plus receiving yards and the
Philadelphia Eagles
five not four uh two plus sacks odds are
plus five hundred you can tail us on
DraftKings again I said this there's no
better feeling than hitting your Super
Bowl same game parlay by halftime that's
what this will do I'm not even worried
about the full time this is hitting no
matter what it's can you enjoy Rihanna
at halftime with cash in your pocket I
think you can
agree love that disagree absolutely love
that
um and people are saying we can boost
this parlay so we got to figure that out
as well
um okay all right Ryan we have our own
boost though like that transition there
we have our own boots so Ryan it is the
last game of the season our final Squad
ride boost of the Year people forget we
are 3-0 in the playoffs Ryan what is
that boost
uh people may forget I have not
forgotten this boost is simple
the man that has haunted us all year
because we have chosen not to put him in
his anytime TD Boston Scott
to have 10 plus rushing yards is being
boosted to plus 150. all he has to do
this is what I'm telling you all he has
to do is touch the ball one time
he will get these rushing yards he will
cap off the season we're gonna cap off
the season finally winning a bet with
Boston Scott and it's going to be
glorious and that's what I'm excited for
here so that's the Boost go bet it
Boston's got 10 plus rushing yards on
DraftKings being boosted to Plus 150.
that's a that's a pretty damn good boost
because he has been hitting the over on
that easily and also just like game
script stuff you're gonna expect the
Eagles to run the ball a lot they have a
lot of backs which you know if you if
you wanted to be a negative Nelly you
would say that but
um you know Boston Scott is has been
crushing this 10 plus not much you hit
it on one run pretty electric
um I will say you know just look at the
chat right now I don't know if we've
ever got this much love for like like
there's no one that's like this parlay
is ass I know we've moved on from the
parlay but there's a lot of fire parlay
Yes W so just Immaculate Vibes in the
chat uh for the Super Bowl absolutely
love to see it right yeah love for the
parlay not love for guac so I thought
you're saying
not love for Boston Scott uh hello
Boston Scott love love it
um yeah man this this one this this
should be a fun one
um all right Ryan
novelty props novelty props I think are
the best part of the Super Bowl you know
we talked at the start of the show like
what are the best betting days of the
year but like even with March Madness
right you don't get what you get in the
Super Bowl where you can bet on
literally anything coin toss everything
so Ryan why don't you talk through show
the people what some you know there's a
million options on DraftKings what the
novelty props are then you and I will
try and sell the chat on our individual
favorite novelty prop
for sure so
like you said Sam it's the best part of
Super Bowl so you look here you could
bet on the coin toss result you could
bet on a team when the coin toss and win
the game I will say there may not be a
worse way to lose your bet if you say
bet on the Chiefs to win the coin toss
and win the game
do you think there's anyone out there
that's like laying the minus 400 on no
like that yeah and then getting cooked
there that yeah
I'm sorry that's just that that's so
funny uh when the coin toss Gatorade
color
um position of the MVP there may be
somebody who's laying minus 650 on
quarterback whether it's Jalen hurts or
Pat Mahomes this one was really
interesting to me when I was looking at
it last night which is interesting
combined jersey number of all touchdown
scorers like if Travis Kelsey scores
twice this this is Cash yeah minus one
six yeah that is it you kind of like
gotta do the math of like what is the
expected number of touch I mean it's
like a goofy one but there is like a lot
of strategy in it as well so that's a
fun one yeah the the jersey number of
the first touchdown scorer also running
you know the numbers through my head and
I was like oh AJ brown but AJ Brown's 11
Jalen hurts is one so like uh Jared
McKinney won
yeah it's it's yeah it's a it's a it's a
scary one jersey number of last
touchdown scores so there's a ton of a
Flea Flicker to happen octopus
kick to hit the goal post first all
right Ryan try it try and sell the chat
on your favorite novelty prop and then I
will sell the chat on mine okay so so
this to me is very simple I I don't want
to count this as my best bet because I
don't want to potentially ruin my best
bet but I will say that this there's no
way this isn't hitting team to make
first coaches challenge the Eagles at
plus 100 is an absolute joke there is no
bigger me guy when it comes to head
coaches in the NFL than Nick siriani
Nick siriani makes every game about
himself and has no problem letting
people know the Eagles are challenging
first he's going to want people to know
that he is what's the correlation
what's up from what's the correlation
from Nick siriani wants to make the game
out of like that he's just gonna throw a
challenge flag so people go like Nick
siriani knows what he's doing okay yes
exactly there's the clip of him saying I
know what the f I'm doing yeah okay that
is fair all right you got me you sold me
uh that's actually pretty good that's a
pretty good sales sales yeah I mean for
him to be able to walk away from this
game being like I am the golden god I am
a guru for like I saw that better than
the refs like that is just the most Nick
syriani thing I think I could possibly
Envision so yeah because he taunted the
cowboys after he beat Cooper Rush well I
mean yeah right yelling how about them
Eagles after you beat Cooper rushes
that's that's a joke so yes I don't
disagree
um yeah all right my turn should I slam
the desk my turn yes all right I'm gonna
make this very simple
there is no other bet on the board that
has a rhyme attached to it caching
Tails never fails it is literally a law
by the gods by
football the person who invented
football it is built into the fabric of
the game that Tails never fails so you
got to take Tails and also there's no
better way to start your Super Bowl
Sunday than having a win before the game
has already started so you get that coin
toss and you hit Tails which again it's
a lock it's law it's science it's math
it hits and then you can say oh you know
when the Eagles are down 10 in the
second quarter or when the Chiefs are
down 10 I can just throw this 50 bucks
on a live bet at plus 300 and try and
quadruple my money it's the best it's
the most electric you get everyone
you're partying about with them bat with
you it's just it's the best and also I
know this is a long take it's also a
plus 100. so you know people say like
when they're taking spread bets they're
like it's 50 50. and I'm sure people are
out here making some bets today
just because they you know they don't
necessarily believe in it but they want
that 50 50 chance but with the coin toss
you don't have to pay that 10 cents and
my dog's in the background so you can
see your high off
um you don't have to pay that 10 cents
you get the no juice so a true 50 50
take Tails
yeah so just just because you we are
going to ask the chat you know which one
uh they want to actually take uh so I
ran some quick numbers while you were
talking because you you said it's law uh
two of the last three uh coin tosses
have been hits
sure but those like those were in weird
years this is like we're back at the
normal a normal year right those don't
oh so now you see you're only embracing
my my Mantra which is like it doesn't
count if it goes against correct yeah
you went you hit at a 90 rate on your
NFL that's the season
my sales hits every time yeah right
exactly if you just look at the best
best it's fine so right if you just look
at the Super Bowl three years ago then
Sam you're you're right tail sets every
time yeah so uh all right I will ask the
chat uh uh are you in or are you are you
taking both of ours are you taking none
of ours do you have a yeah if you have
another one you like throw that in there
money killer says got Tails minus 103.
that's so good that's still good value
you have something that should be priced
at minus one thousand and minus 103. you
cannot beat that
um both teams to make a field goal
um from 35 yards or longer
that you know I would you know I like to
I like to be positive for the chat the
only thing that I don't like about that
is
the Eagles anytime it's you know they're
gonna go for it so yeah you know if it's
Fourth and three from like the 29
they're gonna go for that and I think
the Chiefs will go for it as well so
that seems really easy like you look at
that like they just need to like hit a
semi-long field goal but both these
teams are super aggressive I think
there's gonna be a lot of points today
that's kind of a scary one
uh I agree anytime they're fourth and
short it's just kind of like I don't
know when we're watching the NFC
championship game last week it was just
like any time it's Fourth and short it's
again
yeah they're going and they're getting
it they have well they have the cheat
code which
that should be banned next year you
should not be able to just do the push
push and get automatic first down for
every time
um yeah but that's neither here nor
there rels likes yellow Gatorade
um I did see I can't remember if it was
Jason Kelsey or Lane Johnson but one of
the Eagles offensive linemen said that
they always have yellow Gatorade so
um basically like betting on the Eagles
to it betting on Eagle's moneyline yeah
and I think it's down to like plus 130
or something so it is sort of priced 25
yeah so and they had and that they had
sorry the Eagles had yellow Gatorade
last time on the Super Bowl too so I
feel like you know these teams are
probably superstitious you're probably
not changing from that
um yeah well also Ritter said orange
Gatorade I'm surprised he doesn't want
to bet none at plus 1300 it could be it
could be guac I mean
like Jesus it's gonna be a cheeseable
situation uh there you go Brian Brian
theer asks what's with the octopus thing
which I think that probably a lot of
people have questions about what an
octopus is an octopus is when you bet on
an individual player and it can't be
like the quarterback's throwing it has
to be like the person catching it or
running in
um to square a touchdown and then score
the ensuing two-point conversion so
Travis Kelsey catches a 10-yard
touchdown the Chiefs go for two he
catches the two point conversion that's
an octopus that's a fun bet
it's a fun bet it's just that is
stressed like I have never experienced
before I mean yeah it's probably not
gonna hit I'm sure it's like plus 1500
but uh it's a fun one
um all right wait you didn't why did you
not read 11 A.D 11 said you sold me on
siriani Philly first challenges a lock
Ryan's goated it seems like I said that
is a good bet I like yeah you kind of
sold me too honestly so uh minus the
golden part minus the go yeah of course
yeah of course
um all right Ryan let's should we do
Best Bets you know it's your role shows
near and end uh yeah Ryan what is your
number one favorite bet in this entire
game go
that's how you're teeing me up I'm nine
and three on my best bet Sam I'm 93. I'm
I am oh I'm sorry I had the salary yeah
no no it's okay it is nine and three it
is nine and three I'm surprised we
haven't named this segment Ryan's best
bet
um
with the percentage that I'm hitting at
uh but that's okay but the opportunity
to go ten and three on the season is not
oh my God
I laid down in bed last night and I had
a lot of things going on in my head and
then I thought a big old mock said it
earlier everyone's on Kenneth gainwell
rushing
I am on Kenneth gainwell over one and a
half receptions I think this is a check
down Charlie game for Jalen hurts I
think Kenneth gainwell is the guy and I
think this this has the potential to hit
very early I think Kenneth gainwell gets
involved in this game I know everyone's
on his rushing I'm on his receiving so
give me Kenneth getting well over one
and a half receptions and let's go ten
and three let's go ten and three
um all right I'll get my best bet you
probably can see my outfit you're you
know for a lot of red you're probably oh
Sam's gonna take Chiefs Chiefs my line
well that that is not the case uh this
uh Philly's hat if you're not a baseball
fan out there I'm taking the the Eagles
today
um you know obviously it's scary to go
against my homes but and I think the
Chiefs probably someone else said this
so I'm stealing a line from someone else
but the Chiefs probably have the three
best players in this game with uh Chris
Jones Kelsey and Mahomes but the Eagles
have the best players four through 40.
like that to me that is the difference
in the game the Chiefs have the top end
talent but the Eagles are so much deeper
they don't have Mahomes but everywhere
else across the board every other
position group the Eagles have the edge
and they have the best pass rush I think
they can get to Mahomes and if they can
put some pressure on him and yes his
ankle is better but I don't think it's
at 100 obviously we're betting at some
of that in our parlay so they can take
him down or grab some get some pressured
him and we even saw that in the Bengals
game when he kind of got to move around
and throw on the run like the ankle was
bothering him I could see that happening
today but I just think the Eagles are
too deep I think they're too deep on the
offensive line they're too deep on the
defensive line they got the secondary I
think hurts you know people forget that
Hertz has kind of been hurt and he was
missing on some deep balls in the 49ers
game those two weeks probably helped him
too so I like Philly moneyline today I
think they get it done I decided for the
NFC championship game I thought the
Niners and Eagles were the two best
teams left I still believe it I think
the Niners would have won that game
Brock rating hurt but neither here nor
there uh I think the Eagles win this
game
or if Kyle Shanahan challenged the catch
you know who knows yes but that was
maybe I can't do this that was the worst
game of my life that was a classic
everything could possibly go wrong game
so wait I have a question for you does
the storyline of the Philadelphia Union
the Philadelphia Phillies and the
Philadelphia Eagles all coming in second
place this year not you haven't you
haven't taken that into account at all
it's similar to the heads tail situation
law of averages you know it's like they
gotta win eventually Tail's got to come
back around eventually
I don't know this is that there's no
average though because they would be one
out of three
right I don't believe I don't believe in
curses I'm not a not a curse guy I'm not
saying he's a college guy I'm not a
curse guy I I'm not saying it's a curse
I'm just saying it seems like to me it's
a it's a city that
um can't get it done in the biggest
moment that the city itself is second
tier and uh second place in a lot of
ways you know what I mean
it could be it I'm not saying they are
we'll see
I'm not saying they are also s Reilly
has been calling me an Eagles fan uh
this entire time I I don't want him to
think I was ignoring him I was
um I didn't or I didn't see it I was
ignoring you but yeah Ryan we've given a
lot of picks today should we ask the
chat you know Chad what what are your
what are your favorite Super Bowl bets
today should we grade some bats
Ryan do you think you're ready to step
up to the plate and the grade the BET
segment you know usually you're reading
them but now you're gonna actually have
to start you know giving a few more
grades yeah I mean this is my time I've
kind of been like a teacher's assistant
this whole time right but now I'm being
stuck I'm I'm stepping up and I'm asking
we're all an uncomfortable spots
um Timothy Hendricks did ask what was
the five team parley again so I do think
we should we should read that again
because that is what people are here for
yeah that that I just want to say to
Timothy Hendricks that is a great
username for medicine pretty damn good
man uh all right so the parlay that we
built was Travis Kelsey anytime TD Pat
Mahomes under 34.5 rushing yards Dallas
got her four plus receptions uh
katoni godoni Darius Tony 25 plus
receiving yards and the Philadelphia
Eagles two plus sacks uh odds are plus
500. so that is the parlay but I want
desperately to grade create some picks
Ritter drop Eagles defense or special
teams last touchdown score 35-1 that's
not bad considering didn't that hit in
the Madden game
thank you for bringing that up again
though Victor Victor
Alegria has hurts anytime TD
um I I get like a b
B plus that's a good bet like I think
he's gonna score
so then you do think he's gonna score
yeah so then why is it getting a b
I said B plus you know I only give A's
if it was like Eagle's money line I
in a while so you know we're a little
rusty but
um I think and I also think like we
talked about this earlier like the the
QB sneak factor I think again I wouldn't
be surprised that the Eagles are like
four yards out and they're like we're
just gonna QB sneak three times in a row
and make sure we get in
um and I think that helps it hurts TD
like you're you're not gonna mess around
this game if you know you can get two
yards every QB sneak like you're just
gonna do that the entire time
yeah I agree again it's it's an a for me
uh I I I love Jalen hurts the score I
think that's that's going to be their
game plan
um all right uh uh Harris kruskick says
first putt to be a fair catch plus 225
what's your thoughts
that's pretty good that's not bad
I don't know I just feel like I you know
I could see that like
I don't know you're not trying to like
fumble you're not trying to like you
know cause any havoc in the first
quarter you're just gonna you're gonna
fare that catching you're gonna move on
with your day I don't hate it
uh my only take here and I'm gonna give
I'm gonna give it a a c is we're not
taking into account that the punt could
either be a Touchback or could be kicked
out of bounds so I thought about that
and I went back to like I don't think
these teams are going to be punting from
like
you know it's if this was like Pete
Carroll he's going to punt from the
other team's 45 like I don't think Nick
syriani's gonna do that I don't think I
don't think Andy Reid's gonna do that so
I think you you're going to see punts in
situations when it's a three and out or
anything like that maybe we won't see
many of them but I do think that's most
likely the punt scenario so I I can see
the vision
um all right someone just dropped a lock
sorry what's up no have you lost more
Seahawks bets this year than I thought
because that doesn't come that type of
slant about Pete Carroll doesn't come
out of nowhere from you no I it actually
did get more aggressive this year I
actually think I did well in the
Seahawks but I think historically if I
think of like conservative coaches he
comes to my first um all right Ryan
Charles Spencer dropped like eight picks
I'm gonna read them all to you and you
just tell me what your favorite ones
okay so he's taking Tails winner wins
the game no Kelsey anytime TD AJ Brown
first score blue Gatorade
which which one of those you like most
uh I actually only liked one of them uh
and that was uh Kelsey anytime TD I
don't know if you saw this the trend the
past few years I think like the last
seven Super Bowls is whoever wins the
coin toss has been losing the game yes
that's true so and I'm on heads because
of the because of the uh the trend
um has nothing to do with with your pick
even though you know
[Laughter]
Harris came back in another punt uh punt
prop any punt to be a that guy just
loves punts
um and he wants to be a Touchback
I I like that oh but yeah like you said
I kind of agree with your tape yeah yeah
okay um all right one you know should we
do one more uh Jason Kelsey anytime
there's a lot there's too much Jason
Kelsey stuff like he's not gonna get the
ball in this game like I saw someone
better than MVP yeah like people had him
first TD is doing the MVP like he's not
gonna win no I I'm so confused on the
Jason Kelsey stuff because he every
single play he is in he's ineligible to
catch the ball
yeah yeah they have yeah they do yeah
they're gonna have to announce it to the
stadium hey he's eligible you know and
then what and then you're gonna tell me
that Andy Reid's not gonna be like I
wonder what they're trying to do yeah
it's going to be a gonna be a Decor
situation
um all right that was fun Ryan should we
review all the pics from today's show
uh yeah let's do it uh so we can go
start back with the parlay again Travis
Kelsey anytime touchdown Pat Mahomes
under 34 and a half rushing yards Dallas
Goddard four plus receptions cadarius
Tony 25 plus receiving yards and the
Philadelphia Eagles to have two plus
sacks five legs plus 500 tail us on
DraftKings can you boost it that's TBD I
have no idea but the chat has been
saying yes I don't know if you can I
don't know go check it out maybe you can
maybe you can plus 500 is good either
way
our DraftKings at uh DraftKings boost is
Boston Scott 10 plus rushing yards
Boston Scott the king of the chat all
season long we're boosting that to plus
150. go bet that on DraftKings uh Sam's
best bet the Philadelphia Eagles money
line breaking the curse of being in
second place of the second place City
second tier City second place I've been
second place and Best Bets to all season
long so it's like it's fitting that I
would say that yeah that's true yeah
yeah and you're gonna finish in second
place too which is tough that that sucks
for you uh and then my best bet the
golden god of Best Bets uh the guru of
Best Bets Mr nine and three is what they
call me quite frequently they walk by me
on the street they go oh my God that's
the guy who's nine and three
yeah they're gonna call them they're I'm
gonna be known as the 10-3 guy after
today though Kenneth gainwell over one
and a half receptions like I said check
down Charlie for Jalen hurts today I I
don't like it I love it uh that is my
best bet
love it all right yeah tell us on all
these fade us on all these do whatever
you want to do
um man this is it what a season this is
this has been a lot of fun we've been
doing this show since what first week of
September is our you know an hour mid
February so been a hell of a ride
hopefully we've we've won you some money
chat you've been amazing Ryan would you
like to to bid farewell to the NFL chat
yeah no thank you you said it all this
is this has been great uh I I have very
much enjoyed
um you know the people telling me how
good I am at this and then the people
who when I lose tell me that I suck and
that's just the way that this show rolls
and I love everyone for it
um but yeah like you said this has been
great uh signing off for the last time
for the NFL season let's win some money
be great Eli everyone love everyone have
a Super Bowl
good
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]